You’re a researcher working at Site-19 for
the SCP Foundation, just going about your
day, minding your own business.
You’ve spent your morning keeping an eye
on the D-classes who are keeping their eyes
on SCP-173, while also.
The clock strikes noon, and you decide to
break for lunch, where you’ll enjoy the
delicious tuna sandwich you made for yourself
this morning.
You’re sitting alone in one of Site-19’s
numerous employee break rooms, chewing the
first bite of your sandwich as you try in
vain to wrap your head around SCP-055, the
unknowable Anti-Meme, when a scent wafts past
your nose.
It’s the worst thing you’ve ever smelled,
like a mix of body odor, dirt, and musty,
old clothes.
You turn to look for the source of the smell,
and suddenly realize that you’re not alone
in the room.
There’s a man standing next to you - he’s
tall, with a scruffy face lined by age.
He’s wearing a long woolen coat that dangles
past his knees.
He doesn’t say a word though, he’s just
staring - but not at you, at your sandwich.
Before you can open your tuna filled mouth
to say something, his greatcoat opens, and
a long, green tentacle slithers out, grabbing
your sandwich and pulling it out of your hands.
You start to protest, and then another limb
emerges from the coat, long and reptilian.
It places a single finger up to your lips
and shushes you.
The tentacle lifts your delicious tuna sandwich
up to the strange man’s face, and he starts
to eat it in front of you, maintaining eye
contact the entire time.
Then, after he finishes your lunch, he just
turns and makes his exit, leaving you alone
in the breakroom… and hungry.
Later that day, you request a meeting with
your supervisor, hoping to get some answers
about what you saw in the breakroom, maybe
some compensation for the stolen sandwich,
or at the very least, a little sympathy for
how hungry you’ve been all afternoon.
But your supervisor does none of that.
Instead the color drains from their cheeks
and they begin to sweat.
You ask what’s wrong, and your supervisor
murmurs one brief sentence.
“You just met the most powerful person in
the world.”
Of course, you’ve heard of the O5 Council.
They’re the most powerful people in the
entire SCP Foundation, both in terms of institutional
control, and perhaps even literal raw power.
Depending on who you ask, they may be a group
of elite Foundation agents and researchers
who rose to the very top of the pyramid, a
secret room full of dusty, old power-hungry
bureaucrats, or a cabal of super-powered beings
that transcend the bounds of our dimension.
In short, almost nobody is more powerful than
the Foundation’s O5 Council.
But who Oversees the Overseers, if anyone
at all?
If they do exist, then who’s the one figure
in Foundation lore more secret than the most
secretive group imaginable?
There’s only one answer to this question:
A figure known only as...The Administrator.
If you spend enough time researching the affairs
of the SCP Foundation, there’s no doubt
you would have heard the name - perhaps in
a heavily-redacted file, or whispered in fear
by a Site Director worrying about incurring
the mysterious figure’s wrath.
Today, we intend to do the impossible, and
we just might end up terminated by the Red
Right Hand because of it, but we’re going
to gather all the information available to
us, and try to figure out who or what the
clandestine Administrator actually is.
We’ll answer your most obvious question
first: What’s with those weird, sandwich-stealing
arms?
One of the few almost universally-accepted
facts about the Administrator is their possession
of SCP-262, also known as the Coat of Many
Arms.
Little to nothing is known about the coat’s
history before it came into the Administrator’s
possession, and given the huge amount of power
the Administrator wields within the Foundation,
nobody has the authority to press them for
further information.
The coat’s interior is a spatial anomaly,
from which a huge number of anomalous limbs
can emerge and perform tasks on the wearer’s
behalf.
It’s such a useful item that the Foundation
has even considered weaponizing it for field
agents, as the arms emerging from the coat
are able to perform tasks as diverse as playing
the piano with two or more hands, to blocking
attacks directed towards the wearer that otherwise
would have been fatal.
The limbs themselves are also varied, from
normal-looking human limbs to tentacles and
paws.
The Administrator only finally surrendered
the coat to the Foundation in the end because
it was taking up too much space in their closet,
and they presumably needed the room for the
next season’s most fashionable anomalous
clothing.
For centuries though, you wouldn’t see the
Administrator without the many armed coat.
That’s right, centuries.
Another almost universally-accepted fact about
the Administrator is that they have truly
freakish longevity, potentially living for
hundreds of years.
There has likely been more than one Administrator
during the Foundation’s extremely long history,
but each one has survived longer than any
average human.
It’s also a widely believed theory that
the Administrator may have been a key player
in the Foundation’s initial creation, too.
There’s been a number of potential names
speculated for the Administrator, including
Frederick Williams, Agnes Peterson, Kismet,
and the sinister alias, The Spider.
Some believe the Administrator to be fundamentally
human, despite certain anomalous qualities,
while others speculate that they’re the
furthest thing from human.
This interpretation maintains that the Administrator
is an entity from a different dimension known
as “The Plane Where Eyes Can’t Follow”,
and has a freakish body made from a twisted
charcoal-like material, tangled with wire
mesh and a chaos of different limbs - all
hidden under SCP-262.
But hey, the Administrator’s species isn’t
nearly as interesting as their potential role
within the Foundation, an issue surrounded
with nearly as much confusion and controversy
as...well, everything else about them.
And just like everything else with the SCP
Foundation, the line they feed the public
is often different to the words circulating
within the Foundation’s higher clearance
levels.
If you want to believe the official stories,
then the Administrator is the liaison between
the Foundation and the numerous world governments
that need to cooperate with them to ensure
the successful capture of anomalies.
The Administrator is only allowed to edit
SCP Files, not actually write them, due to
apparent “conflicts of interest.”
In many ways, the Administrator is presented
as your typical sleazy Washington insider:
Schmoozing with politicians and government
figures to make sure they remain sympathetic
to the Foundation’s cause.
According to observations from people outside
the Foundation who’ve worked with the mysterious
figure, they have a penchant for finely tailored
suits, expensive aged liquors, and the amorous
company of women.
Despite being a bit of a drunken horndog,
though, people tend to describe the Administrator
as likable and easy to get along with, regardless
of where you fall on the political spectrum.
They’re also respected by many, and whenever
something upsets them, even powerful world
leaders are eager to try and appease them.
Maybe because they are described as being
freakishly strong when the situation demands
it.
Hey, even world leaders can change their minds
when they have their arms twisted, literally.
While there’s nothing too outwardly bizarre
about this iteration of the Administrator,
we don’t actually know how much of this
is true, a fact that really shouldn’t surprise
you by now.
And if being well-versed in the world of SCPs
has taught you anything, it’s that the SCP
Foundation’s PR and disinformation teams
are not to be trusted.
So who can be trusted?
Is there any perspective on this mysterious
figure that can be taken reliably?
The short answer is… no, not really, but
we do have the next best thing: Recollections
from some of the Foundation’s most trusted
researchers and personnel, and even some of
the strange historical figures that have heard
about or even run into the administrator.
What follows are some of their answers to
the question, “Who is the Administrator?”
Professor Kain Pathos Crow said, “Oh, he’s
just something people talk about over lunch
or when they’re between assignments.
It kills time, and it’s a fun game to speculate
on who really calls the shots in this crazy
world.”
Field Agent Fritz Willie said, “I like to
tell people he’s my brother.”
Foundation Researcher Dr. Snorlison said,
“I’d like to poke at him and see what
happens.
Just to see if any of the rumors about being
made entirely of legs and toes are true.
Or something like that, at least.”
Director Neil Ghost said, “No big deal,
son.”
The ever-stoic Dr. Charles Gears said, “There
are no records of anyone by that name working
for the Foundation.”
Dr. Iceberg said, “Whatever the bossman
said goes.
I’m not on staff to care about last decade’s
rumors.”
Dr. Glass said, “Never met the guy.
Heard he’s pretty interesting, though.
I’d love to sit down and have a chat with
him, but he’s probably too busy.
I’ve never even gotten a call back about
it.”
The wildcard Dr. Alto Clef said, “Who?”
Dr. Chelsea Elliott said, “I’ve actually
done some research on him.
Earliest records are about sixty years ago,
and beyond that there's some vague references
to a 'leader'.
Most of the records, though, are incomplete
or just references by name.
Not much of substance.”
Dr. Frederick Heiden said, “Please, leave
me alone.”
Dr. Jack Bright said, “Yeah, I’ve heard
of the guy yer talking about.
He’s just a legendary thing, from back in
the day.
When we thought there were twelve O5's, we
said he was there t'be the tie-breaker.
People don’t talk about it much now, anymore.
Probably because we don’t need icons like
that to keep people together.”
Dr. Jacob Kensington said, “I think he bought
me lunch once.”
Dr. Rights said, “I heard he lives up in
a biiiig tower at Overwatch, and he watches
down on the O5’s from the back of a mighty,
scaled dragon, and he flies the skies for
free!
Or, uh, something like that.
You’ll have to wait until I finish the book
to hear the whole story.”
Dr. Kondraki said…
well we can’t tell you exactly what he said,
but it was short and to the point and he was
later disciplined for his use of rather rude
language.
In an interview later suppressed by the SCP
Foundation, acclaimed horror writer Stephen
King said of his interaction with The Administrator,
“One of the oddest things to happen to me,
out on the road, was at an autograph session.
In Westbrook, I think.
A larger gentleman approached the table with
a copy of the Stand.
Said he was a big fan.
Now, I think I might be a little crazy here,
but when I looked at his hand holding the
book, it was green.
I asked if he was okay, and I looked up into
his eyes.
They were green too.
He said he was fine.
It was pretty scary stuff.”
Dr. Tilda D. Moose said, “No, no, I don’t
think we even humor that one anymore.
It’s like the mid-tier research staff telling
the new people there’s a pool on the third
floor.
Nobody really believes it, but a couple people
every year try and ask, ‘just to check’.
But yes, it’s a more or less dead rumor.”
And Dr. Django Bridge said, “Sure, I know
him.
He hangs out at the pool on the fifth floor.”
So we return to our original question: Who
is The Administrator?
Do they rule the SCP Foundation, or serve
it?
Are they an anomalous human, or a straight-up
monster?
Are they a liquor-loving political schmoozer
greasing the palms of the world’s government,
or a mysterious demi-god who founded the Foundation
and guides it on its quest to contain the
anomalous and protect normality?
The fact is, we don’t know, and thanks to
Foundation misinformation campaigns, we may
never know.
But much like the Anti-Meme, The Administrator
is defined as much by what we don’t know
as what we do.
And according to all sources, that’s exactly
how they like it.
But what do you think is the truth about The
Administrator?
Just who exactly is lurking under that coat,
if anyone at all!
Let us know in the comments and then go check
out “Secret Group that Runs the World - SCP
O5 Council Explained” and “SCP Most Dangerous
Secret Labs and Facilities” for more of
the SCP Foundation’s most closely-held secrets!